ve lo dico subito non voglio tirarmela
ma siccome tantissimi di voi mi hanno
chiesto di farvi vedere gli ultimi
acquisti
vi faccio vedere forse se l'iran 12 mila
euro borse dior 7850 euro borsa di prada
11250 6,7 euro balenciaga soltanto 8.760
euro jimmy choo
se non sbaglio 1.850.000 euro
[Musica]
non ti far finta di studiare mentre
guardi la tv chuck bere dalla bottiglia
c'è fare l'attrice
[Musica]
no
che bella persona che sai cos'è
hai avuto un'infanzia difficile la mamma
non ti dicevo ma chi ti voleva bene o
era papà che non veniva a vedere le due
partite di calcio io vi ringrazio ma
bisogna fare attenzione perché la
bellezza è un'arma a doppio taglio
aiuta negli affari ma rende più
difficile il rispetto
anche se ai 31 non pensi di essere pro
vecchia per fare musical i loro di
smetterla
qui invece quanti anni hai e 38 non
pensi che siano già troppi anni che non
si fa gli affari tuoi ma anche ai 21
[Musica]